so today's draft the veteran players
who should be most concerned about their
team's draft on the most notice moving
forward you've got the trivia question
to determine the first overall pick lay
it on me
all right here we go three rookie
quarterbacks threw for at least 20
touchdown passes last year mike kyler
murray daniel jones and gardner the
ginsu minshew okay
rank them
in order from most touchdown passes to
fewest touchdown passes again daniel
jones minshew kyler murray who had the
most who had the least
ranked them
this this feels like a trick question
this feels like a trick question
i'm gonna go
murray
minshew jones
uh the exact opposite it was jones
minshew murray
yep same
question a trick question
it is i mean murray was phenomenal
that's where stats can you know trick
you a little bit and also uh you know
daniel jones i think was also phenomenal
i really do and those are three
quarterbacks well two will say that have
a really really bright future i'm not
sold on minchu yet we'll see all right
so first pick to me huh i mean you can't
do it you won't do it i'm glad i got the
trivia question wrong because you will
not you cannot bring yourself to say the
name in this context you can't do it i
dare you to do it
but you're uh well like i don't i don't
want to take andy dalton like that's
where i just feel like it's boring no he
was already on notice you don't know
how is this sailing right over your head
is it really
well yes when you i don't look at it
like oh you want me to say aaron rodgers
i don't want you to i want you to leave
him on the board for me that's the
obvious i'll take them i'll take them
i'm gonna take them just because you
wanted
them
to do one of them
no you don't want to believe
screw that i don't want to do that
re-race erase that nicole in the control
room i'm putting tyrod taylor on notice
i don't think aaron rodgers is on notice
yet i think he's got three years from
now tyrod taylor thought he was going to
be the starting quarterback for the los
angeles chargers we always say this
every year oh sam bradford will be the
starter we're just going to sit carson
wentz on the sideline eli manning will
be the starter and we'll just have
daniel jones sit on the sideline yeah
right get out of here with that crap you
didn't draft these guys to be a top ten
quarterback unless you thought you
thought they were gonna play and what
always happens in these kind of
scenarios the rookie top ten quarterback
he has he's good in training camp and
then he shows some real glimmers of
potential in the preseason the fans
clamor for him and then the organization
goes
why are we wasting our time let's just
get them out there and get get the new
era moving so yeah i think ty rod
taylor's been put on more notice than
anybody where i think when all said and
done justin herbert will be the
quarterback of the los angeles chargers
to start the year
um see i think tommy was already on
notice i think he was already on notice
i think we already knew that that was
baloney from the chargers the idea that
oh we're fine with tyrod taylor no
you're not and now tyrod taylor's in the
same spot he was in two years ago where
he was the starter for like a blink of
an eye until they got baker mayfield out
onto the field to take over so i think
he already knew i think we all already
knew he was already on notice aaron
rodgers was the stunner that was the
number one woe moment of the draft that
was the i can't believe they did it and
they traded up to do it to take jordan
love and then they twisted the knife on
friday night by not getting him a
receiver and then they twisted again on
saturday by not drafting a single
receiver in any of the entire seven
rounds aaron rodgers is on notice he's
on notice that he's not going to get to
walk off into the sunset he's not going
to get to leave the packers on his terms
he's going to have to earn it he hasn't
already earned the right to do it he
only will be the packers quarterback
until he's ready to retire if he earns
it every day and if he holds off jordan
love and that puts him on notice you are
not gonna glide into an easy soft
landing you're not gonna pull the train
into the station you're gonna have to
fight and scratch and claw every way
uh and every step of the way to stay on
the field so i think it definitely puts
him on notice chris that he's not going
to get that easy ending to his career
he's going to have to bring it or he's
going to be taking it somewhere else
well i mean i think you're right about
that i don't think it puts him on notice
for the 2020 season or the 2021 season
if i'm just gonna sit here and be all
lawyer on you and start arguing that i
don't i mean he's the starting
quarterback for the next two years
they're not going to get out of the way
of that but you're right in the big
picture of things after you get past the
two years all right yes he's gonna have
to earn it you're right and you know
he's gonna have to do something like we
saw tom brady do with jimmy garoppolo
which basically was gonna have a
resurgence to his career to go play just
one notch
one level higher whatever we want to say
to where the team kept going well nope
jimmy's not as good as tom jimmy's not
as good as tom so uh i hear you there i
i don't know if i necessarily believe
that for right now but he certainly got
something he's got a hot poker warming
up behind him
he's on notice that he has to have big
years this year and next year or there
won't be a 20 22. i will i know
now he's going to put his green bay on
notice
i know i'm just putting green bay on
notice to say i noticed this draft pick
and it's stupid okay and he's been doing
all those things for the last 10 years
so i want to go like
whoa what has he done that thinks he's
going to fall off any way like to that
to that extent so that's my argument
there but all right here we go we got to
move marlin next oh yeah uh is it yeah
mark is it my pick or your pick it's my
pick marlon matt your pick marlon mack
has been put on notice up in
indianapolis so you know some of those
second round running back picks i
thought were amazing and you know these
teams again they didn't pick running
backs in the second and third round
because they thought oh man our starters
are so good we don't need anybody else
no you know marlon mack's a good running
back he's your backup running back he's
not the elite number one guy and i know
people are going to sit there and go oh
you ran for a thousand yards last year
again i don't give a damn what he did
it's about what was there to be had and
marlon mack fell into that category of
oh
he got 10-yard 10-yard gain that's nice
but
really really top-end running backs in
football would have got 40 yards right
there so he's been put on notice because
jonathan taylor i think is special and
could be one of those guys that's in the
conversation for leading the nfl and
rushing this year
yeah i think you're right and this gets
back to what we discussed last week the
idea that not all of these running backs
who have done well on the rookie
contracts are going to get a second
contract from the team that they
currently play for and marlon mack
obviously now if he gets paid it's going
to be somewhere else barring some
dramatic development but both for him
and for jonathan taylor because taylor
is now the future all right ryan
carrigan's on obvious notice in
washington last year it was montez sweat
this year it's chase young
kerrigan's entering the final year of
his contract in washington a mainstay
there for the last decade he's done this
is it uh he may not even make it i don't
know how much he's guaranteed in this
final contract he may not make it to
week one you're right maybe one of those
guys who finds out and chances are if
he's in the last year of a veteran
contract there is no guarantee there is
no early trigger it's that last year
that gets thrown on there that nobody
ever really expects he's going to play
under anyway it could be sometime mid to
late august they go to him and say we
think we're paying you too much we want
to pay you less and if you don't accept
it we're just going to cut you so uh he
is on clear notice with sweat and with
young kerrigan
one of the mainstays of that franchise
one of the only bright spots in a sea of
dysfunction for the last 10 years i
think he's going to get run out the door
chris
yeah i agreed i mean i think we all saw
this coming kerrigan's had a great
career he did fall off a little bit last
year and you know washington that front
four is special when you talk about the
two alabama guys in the middle with
jonathan allen and daron payne and now
sweat and uh and chase young on the edge
holy cow that is some special front four
so all right my third pick uh will be
michael gallup of the dallas cowboys you
know i'm sure he was sitting there going
man this is great i'm gonna be the
number two receiver this year this is
awesome i'm so excited about it and then
he probably kept looking at that draft
board going damn cd lam's still there cd
lam still there oh gosh and i'm sure he
had a little panic attack and yes it
came to fruition you know cd lamb is
going to be one of the go-to guys for
that offense and relegate michael gallup
to being the third option in the past
game now
you know i thought about going in a
different direction here but since you
went with gallup from the cowboys i'm
going to stay with the cowboys and i'm
going to marry cooper chris because that
contract when it was reported five years
100 million dollars that was fluff on
the back end it's a two-year 40 million
dollar contract he's got two years to
prove that he's worthy to stick around
and that he's better than cd lam and if
cd lamb starts off his career well
you're going to get to a point in 2022
where it's cold objective business
decision we can't justify continuing to
pay amari cooper that much money when cd
lamb younger cheaper as good we're going
to keep him we're going to invest the
future in him and we're going to squeeze
cooper we're going to trade cooper we're
going to get rid of cooper but this
whole amari cooper cd lam thing may only
last two seasons and cooper had better
earn his contract or he's only going to
get the first two years of it chris
yeah well mike i don't think you're
wrong in that logic certainly i mean i
would like to have seen a more creative
pick instead of you piggybacking off of
mine but either way
taking yours and making it better other
names i had james connor in pittsburgh
clearly on notice with anthony mcfarland
there juju smith schuster also on notice
desean jackson they draft a receiver and
they trade for a fast guy in marquis
goodwin i think desean jackson may be on
the outs in philly and i was going to
say mark ingram i was going to pick mark
ingram with jk dobbins there in
baltimore but i think ingram welcomes
that he wants that i think so too
doesn't want to be the guy so it really
doesn't put him on notice it spreads the
wealth
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports